[Musique]
o
le groupe dès l'entré deux mois se
louper on est ici
chez vous l'invitez météo les bons rails
ça va voilà
on compte par la papa la maman l'a vu
passer bon goût salé
[Musique]
les athées les fanico jack c'est normal
on au milieu de nulle part
[Applaudissements]
du parti
d'abord
[Musique]
c'est bon que ça lui bouffer la paraison
ça dure longtemps non
[Applaudissements]
aïe aïe aïe aïe les wayuu intimiste à la
bastille
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est quoi ça mais c'était chez à
lille était la marraine la fée noah et
après et à prix avait disparu et toi tu
va nous porter la poisse
[Applaudissements]
mais on tourne on honda moi je rentre on
dit mais tu fr comment si on tourne en
rond
[Musique]
il rappelle talent est là le professeur
avec brian la manche d'un van ça pue le
mauvais sort je me rappelle d'un truc
par rapport à des du volcan ou
fallait ouvrir son marché sur un van et
il fallait refaire une à la fin pour
qu'il puisse repartir est ce qu'on a ce
qu'il faut pour faire un van
j'ai une plus des décisions j'ai de la
paille je me trouve paris on peut
prendre un morceau de tes cheveux mais
tu veux sortir de là ou pas
allez mettez tout dans la casquette
il nous manque le son est un tissu rouge
[Musique]
et
topp a dû fonctionner bon maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]